[Musique]
c'est sympa
à
je
m
[Musique]
à
de soleil et de chaleur à paris les
plages de rivière connaissent une
affluence considérable la seine la marne
puis même l'oise droite à courir pour
planer et se rafraîchir
des milliers de jeunes parisiens et des
parisiennes
[Musique]
las il faudra bientôt quitter le maillot
revêtir le costume de ville et terre
sous le soleil des kilomètres en vélo de
deux bus pour rentrer chez soi
dommage ou magnifique lac du bois de
boulogne
seuls les signes plus taxés d il est
vrai que les enfants sont plus favorisés
et une piscine miniature leur est
consacré cependant peut-on souhaiter que
la merveilleuse piscine du racing club
engage les pouvoirs publics à
l'aménagement au coeur même du poids
d'une place qui serait nous en sommes
persuadés d'en apprécier des parisiens
même été aujourd'hui paris doit être
fier de ses installations sportives
créer à sa porte mène dans un cadre
splendide et de bien des capitales
peuvent lui envier
un mois de soleil et de chaleur à paris
les plages de rivière connaissent une
affluence considérable la seine la marne
puis même l'oise boîte à courir pour
flâner et se rafraîchir
des milliers de jeunes parisiens et des
parisiennes
ans
las il faudra bientôt quitter le maillot
revêtir le costume de ville et faire
sous le soleil des kilomètres en vélo ou
en bus pour rentrer chez soi
dommage ou magnifique la queue du bois
de boulogne
seuls les signes plus d'accéder il est
vrai que les enfants sont plus favorisés
et une piscine miniature leur est
consacré cependant peut-on souhaiter que
la merveilleuse piscine du racing club
engage les pouvoirs publics à
l'aménagement au coeur même du bois
d'une place qui serait nous en sommes
persuadés d'en apprécier des parisiens
mènent dès aujourd'hui paris doit être
fier de ses installations sportives
créer à sa porte même dans un cadre
splendide et de bien des capitales
peuvent lui envier
[Musique]
la chaleur est revenu paris est redevenu
paris plage et paris slip seul pour
agent ne peut se mettre à son aise et
tout ça nous disent tout l'air de
vouloir lui donner le bon exemple en se
jetant à nous ils ont bien tort puisque
c'est justement ce qu'il voulait leur a
terni
les piscines refuse du monde
heureusement car si tous ceux qui en ont
envie se mettaient à l'eau la scène
finit la part des bandes et
comme c'est bon les vacances
et comme il faut les aimer pour vouloir
partir
[Musique]
les guichets sont avares dans les gares
transformées en salles d'attentes
courage et patience c'est la devise de
l'aspirant au départ
d'ailleurs pourquoi ne pas rester à
paris paris à ses plages artificielles
où l'on se marche sur les mains tout
aussi bien qu'ailleurs
[Musique]
et puis la scène vaut bien amer laberge
d'auteuil feu dès maintenant se nommer
la place d'auteuil
bien que les guides ne passe pas encore
mention de cette villégiature familiale
les sages reste à paris dans ce pari
d'été ou au lac daumesnil
il retrouve la sologne au bois de
vincennes la forêt d'othe et au
montmartre pour bien le mont blanc les
boîtes des quais recèle toujours les
plus belles aventures et seul le pêcheur
à la ligne et les amoureux savent quel
est le plus beau voyage
[Musique]
on dit que par centaines de milliers les
parisiens ont déserté la capitale et que
paris l'été est une ville étrangère
c'est possible mais il y a ceux qui
restent et pour cela les plages de la
seine et de la marne s'efforce de croire
les délices de biarritz août eden roc il
a fait si chaud que certains ont même
pensé à éviter les efforts et ceux
curieux turbopropulseurs a permis à
d'aimables baigneuse de jouer les
vedettes lance torpilles
[Musique]
sur la marne on a eu des surprises un
fuck à joinville le pont n'est pas un
spectacle courant mais il y as phoques
et phoques et le talent de se peindre
des bords de marne explique tout
explique tout et suggère le reste
[Musique]
attention ça mes chances la recette est
simple
de jolies jambes un bâton de rouge un
peu de fantaisie et voici de quoi
occuper vos dimanches
[Musique]